le prix de la république a pris la
décision d'acter ce qui a souvent été
évoqué une année blanche c'est-à-dire la
prorogation des garanties des artistes
techniciens du spectacle vivant de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma qui sont dans
l'intermittence jusqu'à fin août 2000
interne celle annonces majeures du
ministre de la culture
les intermittents du spectacle
bénéficieront bien d'une année blanche
jusqu en août 2021
une nouvelle plutôt bien accueilli par
les organisateurs de festivals de la
région comme les eurockéennes de belfort
je pense surtout que les structures
culturelles donc les embauches heures on
va dire deux de ces intermittents ne
doivent pas être oubliés alors on a
parlé de deux fonds spécifique 1 je
crois et reste r à paris de fonds
spécifique pour pour les festivals
culturels tout ça on attend bien entendu
que tout ça soit mise en place parce
qu'on voit bien qu'en tout cas on ne
pourra pas nous redémarrer du jour au
lendemain
le président de la république souhaite
aussi lancer un grand programme de
commande publique auprès du secteur
culturel il appelle le monde de la
culture à se réinventer pour les mois
qui viennent un message entendu par le
festival rencontres et racines qui
rassemble chaque été plus de 30000
spectateurs à audincourt dans le doubs
mais pour son directeur cela prendra du
temps
pour l'instant c'est vraiment ça
l'urgence pour nous c'est de cet
écosystème survivent sur le fait de
pouvoir à nouveau être opérationnel à
nouveau créer à nouveau proposer des
choses j'ai aucune inquiétude a su on a
tous fui en lui c'est de pouvoir y
retourner mais là le problème c'est que
c'est là c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
une question d'être là c'est une
question qu'il faut qu'on puisse
redémarrer il faut que la maladie
attends attends alors à noter également
la mise en place d'un fonds
d'indemnisation pour le secteur du
cinéma et des séries